are not dealing with the root causes
because this isn't about housing this is
about mental illness and about drug
addiction
you know how many tourists come through
here
and right now with the with the games
coming people walk up our streets what
have we got to show for this is
embarrassing we're standing right now
outside of the only public library in
venice and when you think about the fact
that the library is right here and this
is our parking lot and this is where our
children are supposed to go and get a
book and read and this is where our
students are supposed to be it started
with one tent and then eventually in
less than three weeks all of a sudden
all these tents went up i've walked this
encampment and talked to these people
many of them had told me that they were
from out of state and that they were
just here hanging out right now while
the weather is good many came here and
found the encampment as they were riding
on a bus stop riding by and said oh
that's a good spot to get off the city
has always done this they moved homeless
encampments last april for the oscars
and so that's really their approach they
just want to hide it they don't want
tourists to see this coming in prior to
coving we had about 60 000 homeless
individuals living on our streets many
experts believe that we could be up to
80 000. i think the thing that is so
incredibly frustrating for people like
us who live here who are a tolerant
community and are trying to help people
is that there are billions literally
billions of dollars going into the
coffers and the way they're spending it
is on servicing homelessness rather than
ending homelessness the right solution
is to really treat this crisis for what
it is it's a crisis of drug addiction
and mental illness so the city is facing
this huge crisis and they're fighting it
with housing what we see is time and
time again people go into housing and
they end back out on the streets i think
a lot of the headlines try and put this
as a neighbors against unhoused
neighbors
battle and that's not what this is
because everybody who lives in this
community
is very tolerant we are empathetic we
are we're nice people we moved into a
community that had some quirkiness so
it's i'm not i'm not upset with these
guys they don't have options right now
we are cool with government spending
lots and lots of money but we just wish
they would spend it in a way that would
actually solve the problem rather than
what we call the water bed syndrome like
you press here and it bumps up over here
press here it bumps up over here so it
seems like they're spending you know
millions and millions of dollars just to
shift people around to different
neighborhoods when if they were smart
about this i mean they could actually
solve the problem but the city is really
unwilling to even consider solutions
that are efficient